I'm trying to keep me from Adam Levine
over here we will fight he's gonna do
the full monty here in about 20 minutes
it's cool like are y'all matching on
purpose are y'all like mean to do this I
just like wearing black cuz it spinning
it's really my basic reason I like to
always look like me up a matrix why
would you not want to look like that
yeah that was such a great movie
franchise doesn't want to look like if
you don't want to look like that there's
something wrong with you okay so Shania
is on a show tonight
she's promoting her show real country
yeah my question is and maybe it's just
a theory if she would ever join the
voice do you think she could be the
country starter take all the people away
from Blake all that yes yes any other
country artists could see we're not
country artists so it was like we can't
the most solid chance against him like
up against him yeah yeah I mean cuz she
should not swing so the woman in me
record so I was like one of my favorite
country records oh yeah yeah so what is
the best advice then that you can give
to your team because you know I mean I
it sounds so cliche but individuality
it's like don't try and sound who you're
singing you don't try and sound like
another artist I feel like a lot of
people get stuck in that and we already
have that artist so like try and be you
I know that's there's cliche thing but
it's honestly I think the people people
trip up on that the most but yeah I just
be authentic
[Music]
let's not be crazy not many people could
sing that set last I can't even sing a
damn sound list it's too I'm too old man
I got slower the keys would was what was
I thinking
don't you have to it's like the third
show in a row and I'm like y'all are
gonna get this two steps down because
Mama's tired I was laughing because I
forgot about it and then I when you said
that I'm like oh my god that's so crazy
hey sexy is different for everyone yeah
see they really diminished my my run cuz
I was like I thought you had to be sexy
to be a bigger star hitting you like
stop talking to the artist
I took an amazing run in DC that day and
I ran ran through like everywhere Wow
things I never say I've taken amazing
run through the park and like saw
everything it was really really cool I
never do that I just really want the
time to take it in yeah I don't like to
walk I only leave the hotel so for me it
was like a big deal oh that's me too
yeah I just stay in the hotel usually
cuz I'm resting because my voice is
tired yeah it's so boring
yeah like workout if I can and just like
lay around most the time because you can
you give to literally when you start
singing because it really deprives you
of like being bad on the road okay one
last question our player I'd be like one
last question you post an Instagram of
your kids coming to the set how fun was
that oh yeah they'll be here tonight too
I love I'm coming around because
sometimes I work so much so it's nice to
see them like I got them ready for
school and sent them off but then I
didn't see them all day you know when
they come over stuff so it's cool like
you get to see your kids as much as
possible so they know they've set in
mind there's both of mine I've done two
different seasons so yeah yeah they love
it they love the button
[Music]